[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec un
m'écouter michael annett bonjour katia
bonjour à tous sont invités cette
semaine damien abad
bonjour bonjour êtes député les
républicains de lin vice président du
parti donc les républicains on va passer
tout de suite aux titres que vous allez
commenter bien évidemment dans cette
émission le président du sénat a fixé
les lignes rouges pour la révision
constitutionnelle voulue par emmanuel
macron la réponse du président de
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas tardé le
projet de loi asile immigration divise
toujours autant la majorité gérard
collomb est venu devant le groupe à
l'assemblée pour déminer le terrain
et puis on aura le désormais le droit à
l'erreur face à l'administration sans
risquer de sanctions la mesure a été
votée à l'assemblée et on commence par
le premier dossier de la semaine la
révision constitutionnelle voulue par
emmanuel macron
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président de la république souhaite
que la révision que la constitution soit
révisée avant l'été mais le président du
sénat a fixé ses lignes rouges
il détient une partie des clés du
scrutin jérôme radiés c'est la copie du
sénat pour une éventuelle révision
constitutionnelle caron de propositions
consigné dans un livret est envoyée au
président de la république ce matin
gérard larcher reprend ses conclusions
et promet qu'il sera aux côtés de
l'exécutif s'il s'agit de mieux faire la
loi et de répondre aux attentes pour
réconcilier les français avec leur
parlementaire et la vie politique en
général
mais il rappelle aussi ses lignes rouges
si cette réforme devait se résumer une
fille née à un artifice politique
surlendemain qui affaiblirait le rôle du
parlement fragiliserait la
représentation des territoires
elle serait contraire aux principes qui
guident mon engagement dans la dernière
ligne droite des négociations
gérard larcher se c'est un interlocuteur
privilégié du pouvoir sans qui rien
n'est possible
gérard larcher aujourd'hui est l'homme
fort incontournable qui pose ses
conditions
il affirme ainsi à la fois son rôle
indispensable et en même temps il veut
pas couper les ponts avec avec les écus
tiff et avec le président de la
république réputé pour ses talents de
négociateur gérard larcher voit mal le
président faire fi du parlement en
convoquant un référendum sans vote
préalable des deux assemblées mais je ne
ferai surtout pas au président de la
république
j'allais dire le sentiment qu'il y
aurait une défiance il y aura des débats
il y aura des points d'accord il y aura
des points de désaccord mais en tous les
cas c'est dans le respect la confiance
chaque camp a posé ses conditions il
faut désormais tenter de les concilier
c'est tout le défi que doit relever
emmanuel macron s'il veut aller au bout
de son projet car chaque camp a posé ses
lignes rouges personne ne tient à céder
est ce que vous pensez qu'il y aura
un dialogue qui va aboutir ou bien que
entre le premier personnage de l'état
est le deuxième personnage de l'état
il y aura un bras de fer gérard larcher
l'a très bien dit il y aura un dialogue
un dialogue qui respecte les
sensibilités de chacun
il a aussi très bien dit que la réforme
fonctionne elle ne peut être un artifice
de communication de plus si on fait une
réforme constitutionnelle
on doit d'abord pour renforcer les
droits du parlement seul enjeu très
important
et quand on limite le droit d'amendement
pour les députés on ne renforce pas le
droit des parlements donc il ya un sujet
et puis un sujet sur la
territorialisation c'est-à-dire
l'ancrage territorial des parlementaires
qui te mange au centre la limitation la
limitation du des mandats de
parlementaire dans le temps ça c'est
l'une des lignes rouges de gérard
larcher sur lequel il est inflexible
parce que ce sera difficile de dialogue
sur autant nous sommes favorables à la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
autant sur la limitation de l'entente
dans le temps c'est une atteinte à la
démocratie parce que la réalité c'est
quoi c'est ce sont les électrices et
électeurs qui doivent choisir quand un
député ou un sénateur est bon au nom de
quoi il devrait il ne pourrait plus la
possibilité de se présenter
c'est aux français de le décider et donc
c'est l'élection qui fait ce ce qui fait
loi ici et donc je crois que c'est ça
l'enjeu est donc il nous faut retrouver
cette disposition du cdh à la ligne
gérard larcher ça sera la ligne prônée
par les républicains oui et ça c'est
nouveau et ça il ya un effet et que ça
nous fait sourire mais oui mais c'est
c'est le point positif les rares marchés
est venu à l'invitation de christian
jacob
il ya eu quelques gobelets à l'assemblée
nationale et on a vu une convergence de
vues et les lignes rouges nous avons
défini ensemble elles sont au nombre de
trois
la première c'est le respect de
l'ancrage des députés dans les
territoires et dessinateur d'ailleurs
également sur la deuxième c'est la
question de la dose de proportionnelle
une dose minimale de proportions quoi la
dose minimale la dose minimale pour nous
c'est 10 % et pour 5 % c'est très loin
de ce que promet françois du rgi prise
dans la soirée à près de 30 % oui il ya
un écart important
et là c'est un sujet central pourquoi
parce que ça change la nature des
institutions de la vème république
si demain vous fait 30% de députés élus
à la proportionnelle ça veut dire que
vous avez un risque de plus de majorité
claire
ça veut dire que vous allez avoir un
système à l'allemande qui sera un
système de coalition et enfin un
troisième ligne rouge qu'on a aussi
déterminé ensemble c'est le renforcement
des droits du parlement
la question du droit d'amendement c'est
une question sans
roll évidemment il ya la position de
gérard larcher la position d' emmanuel
macron et celle du président de
l'assemblée nationale françois de rugy
tous est expliquée par françois goulard
le président de l'assemblée répond à son
homologue du sénat françois de rugy
estime que le dialogue est possible un
compromis peut être trouvé mais pas à
n'importe quel prix
il ya des points sur lesquels en effet
il y aura une discussion
l'audace qui est je crois à porter ici à
l'assemblée par la majorité et au delà
et bien évidemment nous ne
l'appliquerons pas et qu'elles portent
bien sûr sur le nombre de parlementaires
mais je ne crois pas que là il ya un
problème insurmontable son union cumul
des mandats dans le temps ou sur le
respect également des équilibres
démographiques qui pour moi vont de pair
avec la démocratie dans les rangs de la
majorité le message est plus ferme pas
question de reculer sur les deux mesures
phares de la réforme constitutionnelle
sur le nombre de parlementaires et sur
le non cumul des mandats qui est des
positions qui sont établis que nous
avons porté en campagne seul cas nous
sommes engagés dès le début du soutient
emmanuel macron et donc ça ce n'est pas
négociable
pas de négociation et si gérard larcher
en fait un point de blocage qui ne peut
pas être dépassé dans ce cas là nous
aurons recours au référendum parce que
nous n'avons pas peur mais les lignes
rouges de gérard larcher ont trouvé un
écho dans l'opposition notamment
concernant le nombre de députés et
l'instauration de la proportionnelle
il en va de la représentation des
territoires ruraux et de l'enracinement
des élus est en train de tuer la vème
république
donc c'est pas des lignes rouges il nous
faut avoir c'est une ligne rouge pour
défendre la démocratie
de l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique
les insoumis trouve que cette réforme ne
va pas assez loin
vous allez doubler la taille des
circonscriptions ce qui va éloigner les
habitants de leurs représentants donc ça
c'est un premier problème dans un moment
où au contraire on a besoin que les élus
se rapproche des habitants je vois pas
comment on va faire de ce point de vue
là il ya une petite dose de
proportionnelle
la question du sénat n'est pas
n'est pas posée donc je pense que c'est
absolument pas la réforme qu'il nous
faut les débats devraient se poursuivre
dans les prochaines semaines emmanuel
macron veut avancer vite sur cette
réforme et la faire adopter cet été vous
avez entendu le député de la république
en marche bien moi qui dit le référendum
même pas peur dit chif
oui enfin il savait je pense que le
prévient la république est beaucoup plus
réservée que le propre député en marche
parce que la réalité c'est toujours
difficile de faire un référendum
on sait très bien que les questions sont
toujours détourné et je pense qu
emmanuel macron comme gérard larcher
comme beaucoup de monde souhaite ne pas
passer par la voie du référendum
simplement sur la question que les
albertains vu des boîtes beaucoup mais
des blocages ils disent s'ils si vous
pouvez pas dépasser ces points de
blocage émirats et les deux points de
blocage qui l'a dit nous sommes d'accord
la réduction de nombre de parlementaires
et la question du cumul des mandats
il s'agit pas d'y revenir le sujet il
est sur la limitation dans le temps s'il
est un sujet important parce que là
c'est la question de la démocratie et du
ch aux électrices et les électeurs et le
sujet surtout comme ça a été très bien
dit dans le reportage c'est l'ancrage
l'enracinement des députés c'est quand
même dramatique si ce n'est dans ce pays
on fait une réforme fonctionne elle qui
fera que demain on aurait des députés
godillots à la botte du pouvoir
c'est ça la réalité tu as inventé les
manuels macron c'est très important ce
point ce que la volonté d' emmanuel
macron il a vu les députés frondeurs et
donc il veut des députés godillots à la
botte qu'ils soient élus par le parti
politique et ça là on n'en veut pas
parce qu'un député élu sur un territoire
et par des sites vous dit le référendum
chiche mais est ce que ce sera un
référendum par la voix de l'article 89
qui oblige à avoir l'accord du parlement
ou par la voix de l'article 11 qui lui
permet de se passer de l'accord du
parlement vous pensez que ce serait
cette dernière option serait très risqué
je pense que ça où on sera serait très
risqué je pense que agité l'article on
sait aussi un moyen de pression sur les
parlementaires en dix ans voyez si vous
voulez pas être inutile mettez vous
d'accord entre vous on a bien compris la
ficelle ce qu'on dit simplement c'est
qu'il ya des lignes rouges et sinon j'ai
sont très importantes parce qu'on a
besoin de retrouver ce lien de confiance
avec les français
alors on va passer au deuxième thème de
la semaine damien abad là mais
l'immigration et l'asile le projet de la
division
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voulue par le gouvernement le projet de
loi en préparation se heurte à une très
vive opposition y compris au sein de la
majorité le ministre de l'intérieur a
tenté de déminer le terrain françois
moulin une réunion cathartique disent
certains députés
le groupe la république en marche en
avait besoin le projet de loi asile et
immigration a cristallisé les tensions
ces dernières semaines d'où la rencontre
d'hier soir entre le ministre de
l'intérieur et de nombreux députés de la
majorité
chacun des collègues a pu exprimer et
ils étaient nombreux à s'exprimer on
était une centaine ce soir des
expériences personnelles des ressenti
personnel je sens que ça que ça provoque
eu aucune discorde
et puis alors les tous les sujets sont
exprimées soient des sujets pour
renforcer la loi soit pour l'assouplir
beaucoup d'interrogations dans les rangs
des élus une dizaine d'entre eux a
raconté son expérience avec des réfugiés
et certains s'inquiètent ouvertement
même si on améliore d'un côté le les
mesures nazis les sky sont ce qui est
indispensable et l'autre côté qu'on
envisage de procédures d'éloignement moi
je pose deux questions quels sont les
moyens qu'on va mettre entre les deux et
je crois que nous avons quand un peu de
chemin à faire pour trouver ces réponses
là ça veut dire que nous aurions failli
un peu à notre fonction parlementaire
pendant 2h30
le ministre de l'intérieur a écouté mais
il reste ferme sur ses positions
là j'ai exposés d'abord longuement puis
j'ai répondu aux questions je crois vous
le verrez qu'il y aura un accord très
générale de la part des groupes qui
étaient représentés là on peut pas dire
que le système actuel fonctionne bien on
essaye de le réparer les discussions
devraient donc s'ouvrir en commission
juste après que le projet de loi ne soit
présenté en conseil des ministres à la
fin du mois de février
est-ce que vous pensez que le groupe la
république en marche qui n'est dit
totalement de droite est totalement de
gauche peut se positionner sur un sujet
aussi clivant qu'est l'immigration et
l'asile et bien les masques tombent et
on voit bien que le groupe la réplique
en marche et aussi beaucoup composé
d'anciens socialistes et que donc
forcément ses anciens socialistes sont
mal à l'aise avec ce projet de loi
car c'est un projet de loi qui est
contraire à ce qu'il pense et que donc
la réalité c'est que ce projet doivent à
fracturer
alors certes certainement pas
aujourd'hui par le vote parce que c'est
trop tôt mais on le voit d'un point de
vue idéologique il ya des difficultés
mais nous ce que l'on dit ce projet de
loi c'est qu'on doit aller encore plus
loin parce qu'ils s'attaquent certes à
la question de l'asile qui est une
question importante mais qui l'est tout
va dans le bon sens et peut-être limite
à projet de loi de droite non non parce
que un projet de loi de droite c'est un
projet de loi qui s'attaquerait à tous
les pans de l'immigration et pas
simplement la question de l'asile
la question de l'asile ses quarante
mille personnes la réalité c'est quoi la
réalité c'est que aujourd'hui c'est vrai
il y a un besoin de distinguer l'asile
politique du migrant économique et la
réalité c'est que il nous faut donc y
est aujourd'hui trop de demandeurs
d'asile qui sont en fait je dirais dans
les demandes sont rejetées et donc les
décisions administratives sont trop
longues et trop lente ce qui crée des
situations d'inhumanité
on le voit sur notre territoire donc ça
on doit accélérer les procédures
amiables de réformer ça nous permet on a
entendu jeudi soir leur évoqué dans une
émission de télé presque haro sur
l'immigration il a fait des propositions
assez forte
aujourd'hui être de droite c'est de se
dire ah les mêmes sur le terrain par
exemple d'un front national et de dire
haro sur l'immigration s'est pas aller
sur le terrain du front national c'est
simplement constater et dire la vérité
aux français
quand le nom de titre de séjour
augmentent de 14%
comme c'est le cas cette année quand on
a en france 260 mille titres de séjour
qu'est ce que dit laurent wauquiez a
juste dit est dit qu aujourd'hui nous
avons plus les moyens de notre ambition
et il dit que limite la politique
d'immigration actuelle conduire à
l'échec parce que il faut que cette
politique soit adaptée tout simplement à
la situation économique notre pays est
aujourd'hui de son s'ennuie c'est
beaucoup trop et il n'y a pas que la
question de l'asile il ya aussi comme
vous le savez la question du
regroupement familial et beaucoup
d'autres sujets qui sont importants ils
ne sont pas abordées dans ce projet car
ils n'ont pas changé de guethem si vous
voulez pierre va passer au droit à
l'erreur
[Musique]
et l'assemblée nationale a voté donc ce
droit à l'erreur vous êtes contribuables
ou entrepreneur vous ne serez plus en ce
sens qu sio n'est en tout cas par
manquement à l'administration car
désormais considérée de bonne foi en
tout cas c'est ce qu'a voté l'assemblée
nationale félix ul quatre heures de
débats plus de 100 amendements étudiés
et deux articles votés le rapporteur du
texte
stanislas guérini est parti d'un constat
l'image de l'état dans son ensemble
n'est pas bonne ce sont 70 % de nos
concitoyens qu'ils jugent mauvaise
leur relation avec l'administration en
général le texte soit donc rendre
l'administration bienveillante
en cas d'erreur fiscal par exemple ce
n'est plus à l'usagé de montrer sa bonne
foi mais à l'état de démontrer la
mauvaise foi globalement les
parlementaires sont favorables à la
réforme mais à gauche on s'interroge sur
sa future application
nous restons circonspects sur le
dispositif proposé d'une part en effet
la notion de bonne foi n'est
volontairement pas définies par le
projet de loi c'est la porte ouverte
selon nous un certain arbitraire à
droite de l'hémicycle
on dénonce les exceptions en effet le
droit à l'erreur ne s'appliquera pas à
certains domaines et notamment tout ce
qui relève de l'administration
européenne les aides aux agriculteurs
sont donc concernés kablia vague c'est
la fin de l'administration toute
puissante
c'est un texte qui va dans le bon sens
avec des objectifs qui sont positifs qui
d'améliorer la relation entre
l'administration et les usagers
aujourd'hui en france ya trop de normes
trop de contraintes trop de règlements
il faut simplifier cela mais là il va
falloir mettre les moyens
parce que les paroles c'est bien les
textes législatifs c'est mieux mais ce
qui compte surtout ce sont les actes au
quotidien pour les français et donc la
question de savoir comment on fait
qui va permettre de contrôler la bonne
foi comment ça va s'appliquer le fait
que le champ agricole ne soit pas du
tout concerné je trouve est une erreur
parce que il ya beaucoup d'agriculteurs
qui ont sont en difficulté par rapport à
ces contrôles donc je pense pas que ce
soit la révolution attendue mais c'est
un premier pas mais pas et ce mauvais
pas et positif
dans ce texte la a fait consensus sur
certains points pourtant il ya certains
amendements qui sont proposés par
l'opposition qui ne sont pas acceptés
c'est le cas de l'amendement dit
lactalis qui a été déposée par plusieurs
groupes de députés modem constructive
socialiste et qui demandait à ce que
lactalis ou des industriels comme comme
ce groupe-là publient leurs comptes il a
été d'emblée écarté par gérald darmanin
est ce que ça veut dire que l'opposition
ait jamais entendu
bon il ya eu quelques amendements qui
ont été adoptées mais ça veut dire sur
elle était symbolique oui celui-là était
symbolique il a été au coeur du débat
lorsque la question de la publicité des
comptes la question de la transparence
c'est une question centrale pour les
consommatrices et les consommateurs et
que donc on voit bien qu'il ya une
volonté d'occulter le débat donc dans ce
texte là oui c'est un premier pas
positif mais il y a des lacunes
il ya des insuffisances et puis surtout
on jugera sur les actes parce que vous
savez dans ce gouvernement moyenne chose
dont je me méfie c'est qu'on fait
beaucoup d'annonce on dit beaucoup de
choses positives mais ensuite on
constate qu'il ne se passe rien je vous
prends juste un exemple chez désolé mais
c'est un exemple très concret sur
l'éducation
on nous dit c'est très bien ce que fait
monsieur blanc caire la réforme du bac
et autres je signale juste à tout le
monde que les décrets peillon il est
décrit belkacem sont toujours en vigueur
alors on une petite séquence
parlementaire a fait le tour des réseaux
cela s'est passé un soir à l'assemblée
votre collègue robert aida auteur d'un
rapport sur le cannabis s'est fait
tancer par la président de la commission
des lois dont il fait partie écouter un
manifestement le rapport d'information a
été communiqué aux médias avant même
d'être communiquée aux commissaires qui
siège dans cette commission
et ce malgré un rappel à l'ordre
explicite de ma part qui a été effectué
au début du mois de janvier
et donc je trouve cela particulièrement
plus que désagréable déloyale d'avoir
enfreint les indications non seulement
que j'avais effectué à titre personnel
mais les indications qui figure dans
notre règlement au delà
de ma personne qui somme toute n'a que
peu d'importance je trouve que ça n'est
pas courtois vis-à-vis de vos collègues
à qui je pense
il aurait fallu réserver la primeur de
vos travaux et non pas aux parisiens à
bfm ou à lci sur pouilles à monsieur
reda monsieur reda vous avez la parole
merci pour ces rappels au règlement
quasi maternelle à notre endroit j'adore
vos réflexions forme les origines
monsieur clédar gelé pour nom j sais pas
ce que vous pourriez de ma merde je vais
commencer leur apport dans un climat qui
vous avez placé dans une ambiance fort
courtoise
on serait on serait à deux doigts de
vous comptiez le redda je ne suis pas
responsable de ce climat
c'est donc il avait instauré dimanche
qu'un climat oui depuis robin reda s'est
excusé donc je pense que l'affairé est
close et c'est un député
bryant qui a fait un rapport un très
intéressant sur le cannabis puisqu'il
est la question des cannabis et c'est de
savoir c'est quoi la question initiale
oui c'était la question initiale donc
c'est dommage effectivement que
malheureusement cette question est
sortie un peu le reste a emporté sur
cela mais je pense que voilà il s'est
excusé donc partis devront s'excuser
pour moi l'affairé close à passer tout
de suite à l'actualité politique de
votre parti si vous voulez bien avec
notre partenaire du figaro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jim gerra fait bonjour je me calme en
vain katia bonjour damien abad
on va parler de laurent wauquiez qui
jouer gros jeudi soir puisque c'était sa
première grande émission en prime time
sur france 2 il ya un problème d'image
ans chez laurent wauquiez tous les
sondages le disent ils ce n'est pas un
leader populaire est ce qu'il a réussi à
corriger cette image jeudi soir oui
beaucoup de français et beaucoup de
témoignages nous ont montré que laurent
wauquiez avait la niaque la
détermination la solidité intellectuelle
la force de ses convictions et surtout
il y parlait directement et de manière
très concrète aux français je pense vous
savez vous qui êtes convaincus dont je
peux vous dire que c'est mieux quand
sondages ce sens des retours de terrain
c'est une réalité partagée et et je le
dis de manière très honnête je crois que
il a fait l'une de ses meilleures
émissions politiques depuis qu'il est
entré en politique
pourquoi parce qu'il a mis du concret
parce qu'il a mis deux lames et parce
qu'il a surtout démontrer aux français
que sa politique et notre politique sans
une politique ce serait une droite de
conviction qui dit ce qu'elle fait qui
fait ce qu'elle dit alors laurent roux
qui joue surtout aussi la carte de la
proximité avec les français il ya un
chiffre qui est intéressant sondage qui
vient d'être publiée dans le figaro
emmanuel macron est considéré comme plus
proche des gens que laurent wauquiez
c'est tout un pan de son argumentaire
qui s'effondre finalement non
aujourd'hui laurent wauquiez est moins
connu qu emmanuel macron et que donc
c'est forcément ça a un impact sur les
sondages mais je crois pas qu'ils aient
d'adhésion populaire des français
emmanuel macron ils reconnaissent quoi
emmanuel macron ils reconnaissent qu'il
a réussi la fonction présidentielle mme
après françois hollande lors nettement
c'était pas très compliqué mais il n'y a
pas d'adhésion ils disent quoi ils
disent mais finalement il n'est pas de
notre monde il est pas comme nous ils ne
reprennent pas en temps c'est la 10
également alors convoqué oui peut le
révoquer
c'est un set en construction il n'est
pas encore connue l'avantagé la force
car laurent wauquiez c'est justement cet
ancrage sur les territoires c'est qu'il
connaît le réel c'est qui sait ce que
c'est quand on parle de la fracture
médical quand on parle des problèmes
d'accès au très haut débit et autres et
donc c c'est ce qu' il veut faire vous
savez bien qu'un politique c'est aussi
une image et quand on parlait de votre
sondage du figaro
dans ce sondage malhonnête on doit pas
honnête ni sympathique ni la compétence
et sont là
en a rajouté plus la coupe est pleine
la réalité oui mais la réalité c'est que
quand on dans ce pays on veut dire des
choses on est forcément accusé d'être
qui vend moins compétents ou malhonnêtes
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que laurent
wauquiez il est qu'il n'est pas connu
par tous les français
eco et plus il sera connu et plus il
sera populaire et ça c'est quelque chose
d'important parce qu'on l'a vu moi j'ai
eu des messages dans les 1000 suite à
l'émission politique et je peux vous les
montre et je les ai avec moi qui de gens
qui étaient pas qu'ils sont pas
forcément encartés qui était d'ailleurs
interrogatif sur l'envié qui se disent
oui m'a convaincu parce que lui au moins
il a le courage de ses idées et le
courage de dire ce qu'il pense et ce que
beaucoup français par il y avait un bon
sondage c'est celui de la fin de
l'émission un tradi finalement il a fait
plutôt un bon score le problème c'est
qu'il y avait très peu téléspectateurs
7% seulement 2,2 de part d'audience
est-ce que c'est pas finalement ça le
problème le problème de laurent wauquiez
c'est à dire qui il arrive à convaincre
son coeur de cible mais que cette cette
base électorale finalement est très
étroite savez on n'est plus en campagne
électorale et que donc une émission
politique a forcément beaucoup plus
d'impact en campagne électorale que hors
campagne électorale je pense que c'est
un examen sur la question de la vie de
base la base c'est un enjeu avait raison
il faut d'abord être solide chez soi et
donc c'est important
déjà que la base militante entre
guillemets que l'électorat de droite
soutiennent et compris aujourd'hui que
le lui seul leader incontesté et
incontestable et et laurent wauquiez
après vous avez raison il ya à parler à
tous les français et donc il faut que la
diversité des sensibilités 60 ans
moi même je porte l'idée d'une droite
humaniste sociale je pense qu'il faudra
effectivement mais embrasser beaucoup
manistes et social juste un point
humanistes sociales
on a vu sur les images dans cette
émission mais gérard larcher à côté d'où
ces drôles de prise de guerre ça quand
on connaît l'ambiance en ce moment de
ceux qui décident de cul rester mais
c'est surtout un fort signal positif et
c'est surtout le ça montre quoi que
toutes celles et tous ceux qui me dit
que laurent wauquiez pas capable de
rassembler et bien on voit qui madame
seul il n'est pas un homme seul
quand vous avez deuxième personnage de
l'état à vos côtés c'est un signal très
fort parce que gérard larcher il incarne
justement cet humanisme là et cette
droite dont on a besoin
on va dire que c'est peut-être le contre
exemple il ya eu le départ dé
constructif de xavier bertrand la mise
en retrait de
d'alain juppé les critiques de valérie
pécresse qui a encore vraiment beaucoup
de gens rassemblés au sein de ce parti
aimez vous savez l'avenir de la droite
se peut pas être que des destins
individuels et la droite ça peut pas
être un puzzle permanents et donc
également découvre enfin c'est derrière
ces jouit
mais ce qui nous rassemble est plus fort
que ce qui nous divise moi je ne sais
pas qu'est ce qu'il ya comme différence
je pose la question sur par exemple la
question de l'immigration
quelles sont les différences entre
laurent wauquiez xavier bertrand et
valérie pécresse
la vérité c'est qu'il n'y a pas ou
quasiment peu et que donc c'est juste
une question de personne et les français
en ont marre de cette politique
politicienne de ces querelles de
personnes
aujourd'hui il ya un chef il ya un
patron il a été élu par les militants
ils lui ont fait confiance et bien
maintenant c'est à lui de faire ses
preuves est ce que finalement ces
départs ou cc retrait se sont pas c'est
pas une aubaine pour laurent wauquiez
qui pourraient se retrouver un peu seul
sur son couloir
on a vu les effets dévastateurs des
primaires lors des précédentes élections
la c1
un scénario qui pourrait être évitée
finalement si laurent wauquiez seul en
course
non mais c'est jamais une bonne nouvelle
la réalité c'est que nous devons
rassembler mais on doit rassembler aussi
avec une nouvelle génération politique
la vérité aussi c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
de femmes et d'hommes sur le terrain qui
rejoignent les républicains parce qu'il
croit cette nouvelle génération à cet
nouvel espoir en politique et donc vous
savez le train aujourd'hui le départ il
est parti donc il ya ceux qui sont
restés à quai et ceux qui sont monté
dedans
dernière question très rapide en
question sur florence portelli et mal de
cas là on en a parlé cette semaine ils
ont dénoncé leur faible représentation
au sein des instances avec des mots
assez forts stalinien c'était le mot de
florence portelli ça donne une ambiance
quand même assez étrange dans cette
phase de reconstruction du parti
oui vous savez tout ce qui est excessif
est insignifiant et la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que moi je souhaite
que mal de câlins et florence portelli
qui sont deux jeunes talents de notre
famille politique exprimer leurs talents
dans notre famille politique que vous
êtes au service des idées prennent un
bon laurent wauquiez jeudi mais
peut-être mauvais laurent wauquiez sur
cette question-là sais pas j'ai vu un
très bon laurent wauquiez jeudi soir et
sur cette question je pense que il faut
accepter dans une négociation que le
point d'arrivée ne soient pas forcément
suivi point de débat de départ est mal
de copains laurent et florence porte
élite ils nous ont dit ils ont voulu
quelque chose
on fait une proposition qui fait une
proposition en suisse sont négociés et
dont on se quitte sur cet axiome la
havane et merci beaucoup et surtout dans
l'intérêt de la france
[Musique]